c'est ce que je sais qu'on refait ce
soir ce bel endroit où ils peuvent quand
même chez kodak hors du coup pourquoi
mais croit déjà ma facture seconde qui
est que je trouve canon et ayem viennois
chiadma question dit de sandrine la wii
tu connais ap t'as jamais vu me feel bad
en pari fou déchiré le match ils eussent
un terminator et de l'arguenon la langue
boucher non non et ça ça donne quoi tu
peux parler la langue du boucher les
nerfs des gros mots bis ouais ouais
comme quoi par exemple cubaine du likès
bilicki je suis clean je suis propre
en fait c'est le mot anglais ouais ouais
je suis bien je suis content mais c'est
au sens figuré non non non non non les
jours ou alors maintenant quand à la
télé on voit que des trucs où il faut
parler en anglais ça vous choque
la somme des fonds semaine ça ne chôme
pas sa réponse c'est un beau s'indigner
et sol et d'eau salée de la nature
jacques rue désolé je ne comprends pas
laisse béton
à
ah ah